hall et à monsieur alain chrétien merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le foll ministre de
l'agriculture j'y associe laure de la
raudière députée d'eure-et-loir le ch
ministre vous avez ce matin présenter
votre plan d'urgence pour l'agriculture
française
ces mesures vont peut-être constituer un
ballon d'oxygène pour la profession mais
ne résolvent en rien les difficultés
structurelles auxquelles les exploitants
sont confrontés comme alstom en quatre
ans vous avez couru après les problèmes
et les crises alors qu'il fallait les
anticiper et anticiper à nouveau modèle
agricole
volatilité des cours compétitivité en
berne
contractualisation des filières et
complexités administratives sans cesse
croissante par exemple monsieur le
ministre l'arrêté que vous vous apprêtez
à prendre sur l'extension des zones non
traitées qu'il fera perdre près de 4
millions d'hectares cultivables à notre
pays c'est inadmissible
non monsieur le ministre les
agriculteurs ne sont pas des
empoisonneurs ils veulent simplement
vivre de leur travail
ce n'est pas avec une mesure dogmatique
à uniforme comme celle ci que vous
redonnerez confiance à la profession
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est simple comptez vous revenir sur cet
art été funeste pour la profession
agricole merci merci la parole est un
monsieur stéphane le foll mines de
l'agriculture
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
monsieur le député vous me parlez
d'abord d'arrêter je voulais rappeler
que cet arrêté a été remis en cause à
cause d'une demande faite par une
association de la fnsea et que la
discussion est en cours et qu'il n'ya
pas d'arrêté qui a été décidée
aujourd'hui par contre je vais revenir
sur les questions que vous me posez
parce que franchement en termes de bilan
faudrait-il être capable de mettre
quelque chose sur la table vous parlez
de problèmes structurels je vais prendre
la question du lait qui a supprimé des
quotas laitiers sange préoccupé sans se
préoccuper de ce qui allait se passer
après
a été le big disk qui a obtenu la
maîtrise volontaires de la production
laitière depuis la fin des quotas
laitiers c'est ce gouvernement
deuxièmement je ne sais pas qui vous
soutenez dans cette primaire à droite
j'ai cru j'ai cru comprendre mais je
vais lui dire monsieur ménages et aux
cordes vocales magané en avons besoin
pour savoir comment avec 100 et 150
milliards d'économies de la dépense
publique vous venez nous donner des
leçons sur les plans de sauvetage de
l'agriculture allez expliquer à
l'agriculture candy millions de 300 à un
million le nombre de fonctionnaires vous
allez être capable de traiter les
dossiers de l'agriculture aller expliqué
ensuite que les mesures libérales que
vous proposez répondre aux enjeux
aujourd'hui des agriculteurs de france
cantonné dans les rues nos propositions
on a un certain confort monsieur le
député faut-il qu'au bout du compte vous
soyez capable de vous expliquer et vous
n'êtes pas capable de vous expliquer
à partir de là je débutais le plan qui a
été présenté a été commentée et par la
profession agricole elle-même et en
dehors des rangs de l'opposition qui se
croit autorisé à parler en son nom la
profession agricole at on dirait que ce
plan répondait aux grands enjeux de
l'agriculture française aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole